so before giving his uh completely
deranged cpac speech donald trump
actually took some questions and there
were actually some interesting questions
asked and trump was visibly uh sweaty
disheveled he seemed confused by many of
the questions but some of the questions
were actually pretty interesting and
this one it's this this
this one would almost make you blush if
trump answered it any other way
trump was asked as many of you may have
heard the president of ukraine has
stayed in ukraine and is fighting he's
fighting in ukraine trying to repel the
russian invasion and trump was asked if
you were in such a situation would you
also stay and fight
and it's like of course he wouldn't of
course we would trump would be the first
guy out he'd say please evacuate me and
trump knows he can't say i would be
fighting because no one would believe it
so even he has to kind of hedge it's
pretty interesting take a look at this
and you know he's not abandoning his
people he's staying and taking up arms
with his countrymen if you were in a
similar situation as president would you
take up arms like polensky
well you know you never know about
bravery some people think they're brave
and they're not brave and other people
don't think of themselves as very brave
and they step up you never know until
you get tested
[Laughter]
even for trump it would be too much to
say i would be out there with with a
rifle absolutely uh and so he
it's actually he he has this moment
where he knows he can't say that nobody
would believe that um i think we know
the answer trump would not be taking up
arms like zelensky trump would be either
in the bunker or in another country
altogether and uh it listen it's more
likely trump would give away classified
documents if he was in silence position
then he would stay and take up arms and
fight anybody trump was then asked and
this was pretty interesting
what would you do differently on ukraine
than biden because trump saying biden's
doing everything wrong and trump says i
guess for security reasons he doesn't
want to tell you what he would do
differently i'll tell you what i would
do things but the last thing i want to
do is say it right now because
if somebody asks me that is in a
position where they can
utilize whatever it is i give them but i
i certainly wouldn't want to be talking
about it right no he it's just not
appropriate and of course he has no idea
of what he would do differently he's
just he says it's biden's fault but
this is sort of like he's prepared to
release his health care plan soon and
he's going to give us the vote evidence
of voter fraud soon it's all just around
the corner also his infrastructure plan
um then one oh now later in the
interview and this is kind of in a
different moment trump is asked about
what what about
he actually does answer what one thing
he would do and he says he would um
get russia uh out of swift the swift
banking system
which happened hours before this trump
apparently just didn't know that very
very important question to be asked
what is the one sanction or the two
sanctions that have not been implemented
to stop vladimir putin that you would
implement given a trump presidency
sanctions now you have to understand
sanctions are very expensive for our
country also
but the one that people are talking
about which is very very severe as you
know is swift
and that just really destroys a banking
system of a country
it's a very big step
and we'll see whether or not that step
is taken but uh thousands of people
hundreds of thousands of people could
die with us and this could spread to
other
countries and it could spread throughout
the world i mean this could be a world
war yes okay so so now trump
changing his tune and saying this
actually could become a world war but at
the time that he said the one thing that
that you could look at doing is swift it
had been done that it happened hours
before trump apparently didn't know so
those are the trump interviews that's
the trump speech it was wacky we'll have
some of these clips on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
and then after the break we'll look at
the non-trump craziness that happened at
cpac
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the only subscription streaming service
just for documentaries i've been
watching curiosity stream at home for
over a year now really no better place
to find the newest and best
documentaries curiosity stream selection
is way better than any other platform i
recently watched the documentary return
of the buffalo a fascinating animal
and fascinating things to know about
conservation of the buffalo as well
curiosity stream adds new titles every
month you're never going to run out of
great documentary content you can learn
something new
zone out on a nature documentary
whatever you're looking for they have it
if you love documentaries you are
missing out if you don't have curiosity
stream it's super affordable curiosity
stream is giving my audience 25 off
which means you can get it for 15 bucks
a year
go to curiositystream.com
pacman the link is underneath this video